&gt;&gt; We saw earlier that we can rate the standard form for the equation of a
parabola as y equals Ax squared plus Bx plus C. So the equation that produces
any parabola should be able to be written in this form. And recently what we've
been doing is taking equations that are written in this standard form and
replacing y over here with 0. So in general that gives us something like this.
Now we know that this is no longer an equation for a parabola. This is not going
to give us any points to graph since we only have x as our single variable. This
value of 0 isn't varying, so it's not a variable. It's just a constant. This
kind of equation, or an equation that you can write in this form, is called a
quadratic equation. Now a quadratic equation has one of the same restrictions
that the standard form for the equation of parabola did. This coefficient A here
is not allowed to equal 0. What I would like you to tell me now is what the
degree of a quadratic equation is. Think back to what you learned about the term
degree way back the very beginning of the course.